he is none other than Tommy so how are
you coach I'm good rich it's hard to
believe basketball seasons finally
arrived that football
winding down there at the end but I'm
good it's been a pretty good year so far
but unfortunately we're only halfway
done well I mean it sounds like it where
are you in terms of your voice are you
already in in postseason mode with your
voice right now coach seems like every
time you know that I got a wife you got
a wife sometimes you got to tell them oh
my gosh look I know you I know Mary oh
gee I know you're cut from the same
cloth I know you just that's true you
don't you only have you only have one
speed I mean how how are things
different I guess now in your twenty
fourth season then in your first in East
Lansing coach Wow my first I was you
know trying to survive although I think
I'm trying to survive now too that
hasn't changed much I'd say the biggest
thing that change has been the social
media and how you have to deal with
things on a such a quick regular basis
but it's it's really been good you know
it's been a good run here and your guys
right down the road they're having a
hell of a year too and you know it's
kind of like state of Michigan right now
we struggled a little bit with our tow
sports but a college sports are doing
pretty well yeah I know Michigan to
Michigan State six never been both
ranked this high at the same time what
do you think's going on there the great
state of Michigan we got the water fixed
I think you know hit the water crisis
fixed I mean it's really been a it's
been a it's been good I mean I mean I
think it's good for the Big Ten too
because all sudden the entire league is
I mean it's as good as it's been rich
you know better than when you were there
and your days but it's it's really top
the bottom I think you know we got ten
teams and legitimate shots and NCAA
tournaments that would be a record ly
seven teams ranked and Michigan has had
a very good yeah I guess in our own way
both of us a little surprising
they lost couple key guys and one to the
league and we lost a couple guys to the
league and earlier than graduation and
yet we we both have a pretty good team
right now
yeah and you don't play each other until
first time late February and then the
last game of the year at your house I
know what's up with that you know it
took us to last year that us in
Indiana's Purdue's Michigan's we all
kind of complain that we should play
each other twice you know we only play
each other at once
I mean it was last year and that's
that's not the way arrival we should be
and so now to each other twice and it
said within days of each other or
something that's at the end of the year
so strange but you know that's one thing
I can't get blamed for not in charge of
his description that's right Tom Izzo
Michigan State head coach here on the
Rich Eisen show how often do you connect
with draymond Green Tom how often you
connect with him you know I take the
dream out a lot I mean you know
sometimes to keep his head up and keep
his head above water and sometimes he's
trying to keep my head above water but
that's uh you know it's really you know
dream on sometimes misunderstood you
know I love the guy he's been he's been
not only good to me but I think he's
much needed on that team he brings
something that maybe they don't have and
it's not shooting the ball because they
got three four guys I can do that I put
it just kind of bringing a whole group
together and you know that when you have
problems like they had like he had you
know not knowing all sides of the story
it's never it's always easy to look at
it but I know there's I think they'll
get back on track and I think they'll
regroup I still think they're the best
team in the league but you got some
pretty good teams out your area but
Lakers get better the Clippers one man
Doc Rivers he's awesome and he's done a
good job and even Sacramento's getting
better so the State of California's got
some pretty good teams right now what do
you what do you say is misunderstood
about draymond Green what do you thinks
the most invested thing about him
well you know whenever you're a leader
and I mean you know both Steve Kurt
Meyer and everybody there is and all
said that he's the leader of this team
and when you're a leader you sometimes
gotta say things that aren't everybody's
liking you know and sometimes you make
mistakes in what you say I mean I've
done that and maybe shut my mouth off
when I didn't need to it other times I
did when I did need to Patricia didn't
agree with it so I think you get you get
misunderstood you know guys got a heart
I mean I've seen him at the charity
events I've seen in what kids I've seen
him what he does and yet sometimes when
something goes wrong you know you
present a different side of him and I
understand that especially the day and
age of the social media you know the
words can turn into a whole different
meaning of something as I've learned
many at times but I still think you know
and and you know what he's young but he
makes mistakes too and I think like all
of us we learn from our mistakes and
hopefully they're moving on knowing and
I still think they'll be you know one of
the team's knocking at the door at the
end of the year Tom Izzo Michigan State
head coach here on the Richardson show
it seems to me that more than ever
anybody that's seated in the top five or
six seeds of a region can win it all
more it just seems more wide open
obviously we saw what happened we saw
what happened last year where there was
some Cinderella teams we saw 16 teams 16
seed win for the first time in quite
some time
forever why do you think it is Tom Smith
was here we played I think it was Popeye
Jones's team and we were a1c there were
16 when we went to overtime and ever
since then I've been a one-seater cuss
times as a head coach and I do 20
minutes that's a good human being he
handled that thing so well that that was
not a surprise to the coaching world as
it maybe it was to the rest of the world
because there is getting to be more
parity kids don't want to play
where they gotta sit even a year much
less two or three like it used to be so
I think kids are transferring more it
just gives there's more volatility
there's more you know it's getting
harder to maintain a roster and so
sometimes people don't know who they
have there's more distractions out there
I think there's a lot of reasons why
it's become a little more like the stock
market you know up and down more
volatile and I think that's get to be
the way in all sports I mean football
pro football has made parody kind of
really important I mean you know there's
so many teams that are ten and eight or
nine and nine or you know in that area
and I think basketball now at the NCAA
level because every kid thinks he's an
NBA player he doesn't want to go
somewhere and go through the process and
so they're gonna go to different schools
and some of those schools are gonna have
success you know when we got beat by
Middle Tennessee we were a - there were
a 15 I think the honestly we got beat we
should add 50 some percent from the
field and forty eight percent from the
three and lost and we were the number
one defensive team in the country we ran
into a team that just they shot well you
know we said what was long I said was
wrong it's an unbelievable that pay and
I think that's happening more and more
and more a couple more minutes left here
with Tom Izzo Michigan State head coach
what do you mean everybody thinks
they're an NBA player you have to temper
that pretty much I think anybody that's
recruited at this level now um you know
the you seen everybody's got to tell
them the same thing since they were in
junior high school to make sure they get
them to the right high school the right
AAU team and things you know there's
less than what I think it's a half a
percent of the players that play
basketball will make it to the NBA and
yet if you if you talk to most coaches I
think they think that 80% of their team
thinks they're getting there so it's
it's hard because there's a lot of
disappointment and and you
when you're in such a fast track to do
things is now everybody thinks they
don't leave by their sophomore year and
it just cludes some problems I if
somebody asked me why is your team
better first of all we're not better
than last year we we aren't even a
better record than last year right now
but second of all you know we went to a
lot of things here last year that were
distractions and third of all maybe the
most important one for me right now
our freshmen and sophomores are becoming
juniors and seniors and like Villanova
like Michigan last year you look at
teams in the Final Four
even a team like Loyola had a lot of
juniors and seniors on that team and
that's kind of the teams that have been
winning it more than the freshman phenom
who are still very good teams but aren't
getting to that ultimate cool yeah you
look up though you see Duke with all
their freshmen I mean it's crazy what do
you think of that kids on I think
they're you'd like to have him as a
linebacker that's what I think I'll tell
you pass rusher actually I mean that
told you at defensive end yeah he's uh
he is and you know that is a unique
human being I mean you take all you know
I looked at LeBron as a sophomore in
high school and if you put those two
together I mean Zions bigger than LeBron
Louis and he is a specimen acting job or
the gym but you know there's there's a
lot approach to basketball but right now
there's good it's really impressive
freshmen and the fourth one might be
there draymond Green you know the kid
Jones I think is the straw that stirs
that drink the point guard who is
probably the least
belly hoot at the bunch but maybe the
most important cog to the wheel all
right last one last one for year coach I
don't know if you you know obviously
you're prepping for Penn State you're in
the midst of your whole season now if
you heard how Sean Payton was trying to
motivate the CNSC that I did hear that
this morning I'm trying to find that
now you're at a different level you're
not supposed to have that money right in
front of careful hell if I did it here
yooper style I'd give the guy a burger
in a coke and that way uh tell them that
if we get to the Final Four that's what
you get yeah first style I love that
what's the what's the what's the most
effective way you've ever motivated or
the most out you know out of the
ordinary way you vote you ever motivated
the spa right before a big game anything
like that good question that I I
probably used a lot of different tactics
depending on what it is but I one of my
favorite things to do is I watch a lot
of sports and as you know I probably
love football more than basketball at
times and I try to look at either press
conferences or things people say or my
favorite time of year is any time
there's an NCAA Championship like gym we
just got down with the football and or
if there's an MBA or if there's an NFL
and they do all the human interest
stories guys like you are talking deeper
into people and you realize that those
are motivating stories and how guys go
from rags to riches and people that
didn't think that when it you know for
us it was back with all the Flintstones
and you know kind of bringing the pride
back to Flint when you were in school
you know there were so many athletes
that came out of that city Bolton
football basketball a lot of went to
your school I don't want our school find
those kind of motivating things nothing
as crazy is bringing that kind of money
in but and if all else fails I called
magic and say can you come talk to my
team got a flood kidding Koosman right
now he's really enjoying I'll talk about
oh man I saw the end of that 41 last
night and that was pretty impressive
especially without LeBron I know hey
coach thanks for the call really
appreciate always love catching up with
you I'll tell Mariucci you said hi when
I see him in a couple days which I
appreciate it love love your show good
work same to you thanks again that's you
Betsy that's Tom Izzo at MSU underscore
basketball the Rich Eisen show weekday
at noon eastern on audience